Hello everybody
welcome I have with me Lea K and she is
going to talk to us about keeping a
human in the loop in order to yeah save
energy in factories is what I've
understood but I think Le can explain it
much better so give her a very big round
of
applause uh thank you for the
introduction and thank you for for being
here on this Saturday morning uh very
proud of you already um so to the next
30 minutes I want to take you along in
standby detection with a human in the
loop uh a project we've been working on
at sense effect uh my name is Lea indeed
I'm the Le the scientist at sens effect
and sens effect is a company that aims
to reduce the human environmental
footprint by eliminating all waste in
Industry we use we do this using a
combination of sensor technology and
analytics and we focus on industrial
small and medium
Enterprises uh when I say allte I really
mean allte so um on the one hand we have
utilities such as gas and water but on
the other hand we also have waste uh
resulting from suboptimal maintenance
strategies but the story of sense effect
started with electricity and that's also
what we'll talk about
today um so the impact of electricity on
the environmental footprint is quite
obvious with every kilowatt hour of
electric that we consume uh CO2
emissions are generated and the
environment is impacted uh and you and I
can do a lot about this already at home
uh but unfortunately our consumption
only amounts to 40% of total electricity
consumption in the Netherlands at least
whereas in Industry 44% is consumed so
if you really want to make a big impact
this might be a good place to
start um if you look at a typical
customer of sens effect they consume as
much as 3,000 households
combined and from our experience even
with very minimal interventions no big
Investments no big process changes we
can already shave off the consumption of
55 households compared to this big
amount that you just saw maybe it
doesn't sound like that much but if you
think of it if you do this for 100
factories you've taken a complete
Village of the grid if you do this for
all industriales globally well do your
math you can get quite
far
um as I said we do this with sensor
technology and analytics so the picture
you see here is um the sensor we use for
our electricity proposition um our
customers use these to measure the
electricity consumption of individual
machines in their factories they can
simply install it themselves by clipping
it around a wire that goes into their
machine um they do this for multiple
machines they also install install a
bridge on site the data sent from the
sensors to the bridge onto a data
platform and then shown to them in a web
application uh this in itself is already
quite useful because you can see which
machines consume a lot which cons
machines consume little did I turn off
my machines in the weekend um but of
course you all know data gets a lot more
interesting if you apply a layer of
analytics on top of it some of this
analytics is available in this web
application uh but also a large part of
it is presented to the customers in a
consultancy um
trajectory so
um when a customer gets on boarded with
us censors are installed about two
months in they sit down with a
consultant and the consultant talks them
through different ways in that they can
set up their U Machinery more
efficiently we call these savings um and
they actually estimate the yearly um
savings for them uh based on their
initial set of
data um we have a quite wide range of
possible savings but by far the biggest
saing come from Simply turning off your
machines and this might sound a
bit strange but um yeah in fact a lot of
machines are running either on standby
or producing while not actually
producing any material or products um
you can think of this for example when
you're cooking something you're baking a
cake you're already start beting your
oven then you realize it takes a lot
longer to create your batter oven is
already running at 18
it's producing a lot of heat but it's
not producing anything material so that
would be Machin is armal it should be
off and then standby I think we all kind
of know what standby
is um so standby um you can see standby
in the power consumption of a machine um
mostly it would look a bit like this
maybe that's a little monitor that's
still running um you have a constant
power consumption from that constant and
low um but unfortunately it doesn't
always look like this because this would
have been very simple right sometimes
it's low consumption but with a bit of
variation sometimes there are multiple
modes in which a machine can be a
standby because the machines that our
customers have are a bit more complex
than your TV for example um and one of
these states could also be relatively
High consumption um so this makes the
problem already a lot less trivial than
it seems from the first
picture um so how could we go about this
in this consultancy process um we have a
consultant he looks at six weeks of data
tries to um find all these um examples
that you see here and then tries to from
there estimate what would be your yearly
waste due to this standby um goes back
and forward with the customer checks is
this really standby yes or no well this
is kind of tedious um probably also Fair
error prone so what You' like to do is
automate this right um and when we say
automation we usually think replacement
so let's get rid of a consultant let's
build some fancy model that does
everything that the consultant used to
do and let this model just forward this
results to the customer
directly
um
unfortunately this is not always the
best strategy um in some case it might
even be une ethical right if you think
of use cases in medicine or law um in
other cases especially cases that we
tend to work on um maybe a machine or a
human would on its own perform worse
than when you combine both
together um so in this case we talk of
task augmentation instead of replacement
and usually these cases the machine
helps the human in understanding a
problem better or help them to drive a
solution which they couldn't do without
it you could say that each of these have
their own unique qualities right the
machine is able to go through loads
loads of data the human can understand
the context and reason about the problem
probably a bit better than the machine
maybe not everyone would agree with that
at this moment but let's take that
assumption um yeah so there are a couple
of um benefits from thinking of a
problem in the framework of task
augmentation instead of
replacement um particularly when it
comes to your model development because
you're kind of forced to make a model
that's quite transparent because a human
needs to interact with it and it needs
to understand what's going on um other
than that you can if you design a system
in this way um it can help you have the
make the human have trust in the system
because it has to interact with it and
starts to understand actually it can do
more than I thought it might
can then there's also the option that if
you design this well you can actually
empower the human so instead of making
it feel less valued because you want to
replace it you make it feel more valued
because you give it something that can
make him or her execute their work
better um and lastly it shifts the focus
away from building a perfect model
because an OKAY model with a human yeah
it already can give pretty high quality
output
uh but in the end what we would hope is
that these two systems together the
human and system um would achieve better
outcomes together than each of the parts
alone Um this can be done in a couple of
ways first there's just direct
Improvement so computer says no the
human says yes and we give the right
answer to our
customer then there's uh algor
algorithmic learning so computer says no
human says yes result is stored saved
somewhere in a database and used for
next iterations of your model so that if
the model sees a similar case this time
he wouldn't say no no but
yes uh lastly there's organizational
learning because the domain experts that
we work with um typically they have a
lot of knowledge um but not all of that
knowledge is very explicit A lot of that
is intuitive I've heard Consultants say
um yeah you just have to kind of get a
feel for it and yeah to get a view for
it we don't really understand what it is
and you cannot transfer that knowledge
to other people but is if we let this
human interact with the computer and
store all the actions that they take um
suddenly this very implicit knowledge
becomes explicit and can be shared with
others um however you're not necessarily
having better outcomes when you have uh
technology and humans working together
um um this is a quite nice example from
a paper by fing Ado um there they made a
tool that helped people in the
restaurant business to make planning uh
we have a model that forecasts Revenue
then we have a domain expert that looks
at this and then adjusts revenue and
based on that planning is made turned
out if you would show them this they
would typically make the predictions
worse however if you would then show
them what did or did not go into the
model they would make the outcomes
better so it's very important that you
build your design correctly and that you
give your human the right information to
work with to actually get high quality
outputs so to oh one more thing uh at
Google they call these humans AI system
operators it's quite a fancy term um and
they say that your design can vary on
three AIS uh one of them is the level of
control so as a human can I choose to
engage with the AI sub system um can I
choose to
intervene there's a level of input um
can I select the data that goes into the
system or can I maybe even tweak the
parameters of my
algorithm and lastly there is the level
of awareness so do I understand how the
system works can I even do forensics on
very specific
cases um so with all that knowledge in
the back of our mind let's see how our
process looks and how this maps to what
we are doing um so here we have our um
little robot and our
consultant um so first robot checks if
on boarding was complete if there's
enough data it starts to Cluster that
data um see if there are similar
patterns and different places in the
data that look alike and that will
constitute like one cluster and then
those clusters will be labeled with
production uh standby or
off then the consultant comes into play
it looks at the results of this uh
mapping and then if it says like seems
off it can change the label from
production to send by or back once this
is done they hit okay uh calculation is
triggered yearly estimated standby uh
yearly standby ways is estimated and the
different um reporting tools that these
Consultants use are automatically
populated and periodic reports and
alerts are
triggered um to do this you need a bunch
of tools I'm not going to talk about
that today may be a great thing for
another talk
um but uh here you can already see where
the learning happens right um so at the
moment that these Consultants relabel
the
Clusters the estimated your and by waste
should be better there's direct learning
then we also save their relabeling
actions and use that for next iterations
of our model um so there you have the
algorithmic
learning and when you look at these uh
different axes that we talked about in
this case we have very low control a
consultant cannot really choose whether
they use or do not use the output of
this algorithm if they want to have
yearly standby waste in their reports
they need to go this
direction um they also have low input
they cannot choose which period seems
representative to them to train this
model on they cannot tweak with the
parameters of this
segmentation and they have mod awareness
they know quite well what the model does
what it's good at what it's bad at um
the UI is very explicit to them but um
they don't know exactly what goes into
the
model and um if
we think about this thing if we want to
have algorithmic learning we want to
have high quality labels we just learned
that if you want high quality labels you
need to have actually High awareness
because you have to give them all the
information that they need to give
proper labels so probably we could have
better worked on this one thing a bit
more um because now you could say
simplified version of our UI looks a bit
like this you have a bit of you have a
Time series of power um here you have a
blue wiggly line then some bums slat
lines in between and some crazy Peaks um
our model says the blue thing is Stand
By and the purple thing is Stand By and
the consultant might look at this and
think yeah but usually would just have a
single by state so probably the purple
one is not standby but if we would now
have given them the information that
this is a grinder and 70% of Grinders
have two standby States maybe they
wouldn't have made this faulty
correction um and just kept as a
standby
um yeah um if we would not only try to
uh design for the highest quality labels
but actually for the highest quality
output being the estimated yearly
standby waste we would probably need
have given them a bit more control we
were afraid to do so because our
Consultants are known to be quite
creative they want to be perfect so they
would maybe favor the manual option over
the model even if the model is quite
close to their
calculations um so they would maybe
prefer to do this and have more control
of what they are doing um I think in the
end we could have given this this option
because there's the thing on the right
the enable periodic reports and alerts
this feature is so important to our
customers that would probably have kept
them in check anyway so I don't think
many consultants would have gone this
road um because you cannot give alerts
based on manual
calculations um then we also didn't
really Empower our Consultants right we
just said this is what you have to label
go on with it um probably if we would
have want them to make them feel a bit
more valued we could have given them a
bit more input um make them choose the
piece of data that the clustering is
done on U make them tweak the parameters
of the clustering because yeah maybe
that would have helped the outcome and
that maybe would have made their work a
bit more fun um now it sounds a bit as
if higher is always better um but we
could have also gone the other way
around and say let's go for low
awareness because maybe that's bit more
efficient so before we had this funky
plot with all these colors it's kind of
like in your face and lot going on
um but you do understand what the the
result of Your Action is but maybe if
you should have would have shown them
this so just blue is stand by Green is
not standby and ask them to label a bit
that is standby move all those this
other knowledge and logic to the back
end and and then just Mark everything of
that segment as uh
production great thing about this is
this you could also show to a customer
right whereas the screamy UI you saw
before for a customer who doesn't have
an analytical mindset it might be a bit
much so even if you cannot take replace
the customer by a machine completely
maybe we could um consultant we could
maybe move part of what the consultant
does to a
customer um I thought I didn't have time
for this but I will so I'm going to have
some extra slides uh here uh because I
finally had some facts about feedback
actually it's more like learnings but
that didn't sound as uh as catchy so
first thing is context is crucial um
when we were designing this setup with
our Consultants we noticed that we were
really not speaking the same language um
we were trying to predict
standby they they were trying to find
out where the consult where the customer
could
save um which meant that even if there
was standby but the machine was very old
so the customer couldn't really turn it
off they would not label that as standby
because in their mind that would be a
completely different thing um of course
this gives a whole range of problems
when you try to retrain on the data um
so we had to kind of make the
distinction between avoidable standby
and unavoidable standby so that they
could give the right savings and we
would also have the correct training
data um the second thing is keep it
simple um when we again were discussing
the setup with the consultant they said
yeah this is never going to work we need
a lot of post Pro post processing on top
top of this we need uh to be able to do
this that that and that um and they came
up with all the edge cases that they
have ever seen and to them these
exceptions seem like rules because if
you think of it an exception maybe it
doesn't occur so much but if you are
working um on this topic the exceptions
are the things that you spend most of
your time on so they really thought it's
really important um we in the end kind
of landed in the middle gave them some
options to do
postprocessing if we now look at of
course we have all that data stored if
you now look at it yeah usually they use
the default we could have just get
gotten rid of all of that to begin with
and finally um trust can be learned um
in the beginning we had to put in we're
asked put in a lot of guard rails um
around this problem and now over time as
the customers are working uh with this
product even though they still make a
lot of Corrections they are asking if
they we can minimize their um their part
in this process so it turns out that
they learn to trust the model along the
way um um then now I can go back to my
final slide thank you for uh for being
here and listening to me uh if you want
to know more about this or about the
technology behind it we also have our
Engineers walking around here today and
um you can always contact me on my email
thank
you